okay you know how this works the little
guy's gone and his favorite story's back
and we're not going to talk about it but
we're going to pretend like we're trying
to talk about it right cat so audience I
need you for once to do this all right
I'm going to give you two stories and
you applaud for the story you want to
hear here is Story one I will explain
the mating habits of the bearded
dragon
yeah
bearded
dragon oh God second
option the Canadian teacher with a giant
fake
prosthetic
all my notes on bearded
dragons Okay sickos the teacher it
is you remember Kayla Lemieux she was
put on leave at her old school because
of security concerns over her presence
teaching kids but now she's been given a
job at a new school and parents are
Furious calling it the definition of
insanity much like this
[Applause]
crowd Michelle listen I don't think any
parent has a problem with they being a
trans teacher if they're a good teacher
I think the problem is the Optics it's
like why the
giant mammory glands with the
paper plates for nipples that everyone
to see listen I be what you want be who
you want to be I have no issue but like
reverse that what if I decided to wear
medium spandex shorts to work every day
with a shirt that said I'm blessed I'm
well hung Arrow points down then the
back of my shirt goes in case you didn't
know I have Clyde's Dale DNA check it
out just me talking about is making the
audience sick but yet you picked this
story but imagine if I did it I mean it
would be completely inappropriate right
absolutely now I will say on behalf of
small breasted women everywhere could
this person just sort of spread the
wealth I mean couldn't we just take a
little bit um no this is this is proof
and this is in Canada so it's good to
know that our Canadian neighbors to the
north are as stupid about schooling as
we are you are putting a complete and
utter distraction inside of a classroom
and on a a school property this is so
dumb this is like you take the the the
cop everyone knows is bad and has done
bad things and you move them over to
another Precinct they've taken this
teacher who has proven to be a total
distraction I I we're in a weird world
where this is supposed to be acceptable
and normal this teacher is literally the
definition of a bad apple literally yeah
Joe the office sends you memos all the
time saying you can't wear short sleeve
shirts because of the vascularity of
your biceps do you think it's fair that
she can wear Giant and it's the outfit
it's it's not like it's like wearing a
nice turtleneck or something well I'll
make a deal with HR that I will not wear
my mesh tank tops anymore if I get that
shirt you just
described
uh I'll say I'll say this I can think of
two giant reasons why this teacher
shouldn't be teaching in another school
uh one it's a distraction two people's
eyes are going to get poked out
but I don't think this is a trans issue
this is a government schools issue cuz
trans people don't walk around with
giant prosthetic boobs this is an Andy
Kaufman level troll that they're scared
of letting go because they're worried
about being called a mean name yeah
because being mean is suddenly being
honest is being mean
Walter your parent teacher conference
and this how would this
go well the thing that bothered me about
these breasts of hers
um or how low they are
um they they really ride low and and the
nipples too which you properly commented
on are like sharpened hockey pucks
um but but but even worse is the fact
that she doesn't teach history you know
what she teaches shop
okay there there's kids learning to use
like Dr real presses and band
saws and somebody's going to lose a
hand or Worse cuz she likes to cut
[Applause]
wood well any kid who actually gets wood
in that
classroom if there's a lumber shortage
right right I'd have a big Lumber
shortage if I was in
the classroom
yeah
now cat I I am so sorry because like me
maybe even a little more than me you
hate this story yeah I've just been
asked to comment on it a lot and a lot
of things to say but I think it was a
brilliant move for you to put it on
tonight you know why I did it because
now Greg doesn't get to do it
yes like and we did it we're doing a
segment on it he probably want to do
like a whole monologue on it he probably
want to do like one segment per he
doesn't going to do any of that yeah he
does to do any of that so I would just
like to use my time to tell Greg sucks
to be you you're not here right now you
don't get to do the
story you know he's somewhere on his
knees going no no yeah he's so
upset take that Butterfield Craig
Butterfield all right coming up they're
suing for Relief claiming that the
burgers were low on meat hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else